no hay duda de quién está a cargo
omnipresentes en las calles de kabul con
nuevas reglas en la ciudad los talibanes
mantienen un fuerte control en la
capital
el epicentro de su nuevo régimen al que
llaman emirato islámico de afganistán
tenemos nuestros líderes tenemos nuestra
nación y tenemos un objetivo lo que sea
que nuestro líder nos pida obedeceremos
todos nuestros hermanos muyaidines
tienen una sola voz todos estamos
sostenidos por una misma mano
no puedes llegar muy lejos en la ciudad
antes de encontrarte con puntos de
control o con combatientes talibanes en
patrullas estos hombres manejan un
vehículo que obtuvieron de la antigua
policía de afganistán que los talibanes
les quitaron cuando entraron a kabul
hace poco más de una semana
y estos hombres avanzaron hacia la
capital desde la provincia de oruzgán
más al sur llenando un vacío de poder
tras la huida del gobierno y las fuerzas
de seguridad afganos la seguridad y el
orden han regresado a kabul no hay más
robos nadie más puede entrar a una casa
sin permiso todo eso ahora está
prohibido por nuestra ley en revisión
hay una amnistía nosotros perdonamos a
todos incluso a los militantes
mientras la vida regresa al centro de la
ciudad las evacuaciones militares
continúan al tiempo que miles intentan
huir
cerca a los límites del aeropuerto de
kabul el grupo talibán muestra otro lado
de su promesa de reforzar la seguridad
anunció que prohíbe a los afganos
acceder al recinto
hay una sensación de que kabul contiene
la respiración esperando a ver la
completa realidad del gobierno talibán